moi je mange ni moules d'huîtres je
suivais gagnent je rappelle les moules
sont des êtres vivants elle devrait
avoir le droit de vote
[Applaudissements]
c'est calme ça me dégoûte yachts haut
que
tout le monde est dégueulasse non non
moi de dégueulasse j'adore la salade de
poulpe alors du coup extraordinaire avec
du persil les pommes de terre un peu
chaude à peu de céleri un quart d'heure
et un peu de villes n'avaient pas plus
de la gueule le poulpe a non pas du tout
goûté sur wii un pool
s'est passé puisque l'appui de la frite
non enfin je peux dire rien à voir tu es
malade ou quoi tu avais un peu de ça
vient de la mer tu as dit ressentir
poudre petit diable la pompe
alors signer que tu me semble toujours
je connais les poux jeannard poux pas la
maison ils dorment à la maison arrêter
de dire des conneries comme les bonbons
j'ai une seule vous sentez pas de quoi
c'est pas du tout mais moi je mens
jamais de sol tu as vu le prix de la
sole et mes impôts j'ai pas l'impression
non j'aime pas trop les sols moi je
kiffe pas trop de poissons dans les
hauteurs du poisson ouais ça me rappelle
de mauvais souvenirs
le plus bizarre
escargots quand tu manges
tu sors l'escargot
fuyard qui va bien sûr c est que
l'escargot bizarre c'est tout vis que
dégoûter tout ça ils sont cools la td
scdma et après tu quand tu rentres tu
rentres pas là
mais valérie le lendemain on se parle
franchement tu es là tu as oublié que tu
as mangé des escarres durera combien
l'horreur
c'est horrible
mais ce que les disques moins chère
juste petite question parce que les
histoires vous faut les manger lentement
qui suit manche de dégueulasse à moi pas
grand chose mais j'étais obligé un jour
de manger de la langue avec gérard
depardieu
mais avec deux breaks de part ça devrait
s'arranger de la langue à langue de qui
est horrible donc je sais pas ce débat
donc assez fait longtemps que
je connais il est pote mon frère ils ont
une gueule on est frères
taloche un boss
c'est assez rare quand on
sait les faire il ya loge mon frère sur
la tête de ma mère il sera pinning à
quel moment ces gars-là chamarré c'est
mignon je suis pas que la question à
jour moi pourquoi je dis alors crespin
mettez c'est un moins diffus comme ça on
l'a fait vous attendez on était jeunes
on l'a fait nous quoi série d'emplois
ouais parce que nous démarchons il y
avait un champ et on allait voir les
vaches panache orient et te file des
coups de langue alors c'est rigolo
c'était le défi coutin et c'est vrai que
ça met toi bien on peut
[Musique]
[Rires]
quand même tu me dégoûtes déjà les
bulots mayonnaise bien gluant corps
et sinon toute forme de crevettes que je
mange entièrement non
moyens addiction à côté de
ces victimes ont été découvertes à côté
de moi j'ai besoin de tout art même que
son député ouais non il prône toi parce
que tu as toujours un truc qui partent
en mer
c'était le gars ça m'arrive un jour il
avant la noël a pris le tout à tout
simplement si tu attends t'es battu voit
pas et 80
est la fille d'un ami mots comme un
hymne à mi chemin mais je te jure on
s'est excusé mais quelle horreur excuses
genre
tu le début du mois
je te jure je te ruiner ta gueule
non si je vous le savez pas tout oui oui
et fats waller bien peixoto pechoux
après non non
non mais oui je manquais ce qu'elle
subit la fat
est ce que vous mangez dégueulasse on a
géré la viande crue ah ouais fait par
carte ou créés trop lait cru dans la
croix non mais j'aimerais ça chez vous
voulez vous connaissez pas non un
tartare de poulet halal est là il est
pas cru j'en ai déjà mangé ce texte
[Rires]
[Musique]
enfin les canards moi jamais un canard
ça change votre canard pour coiffer
cachais en bas parce que ça me dit ça me
fait de la peine parce que j'ai calé à
chauny j'en connais tellement
les faits million seller canard c'est
mes amis ont grandi des voix parfois moi
je tiens à manger comme ça on mangeait
pas daniau la biodynamie de l'année
c'est mignon il apporter vos amis mais
des zapa outil assez malade ou quoi par
contre je mange des carottes en devenir
et ma place à toulon comme
je vous le disais de légende prénom je
mange au kilo de carottes toujours alors
modifie pas vous voyez vraiment
dépassé quand même alors qu'il mange du
poulet
hachée crue sinon mon plat préféré c'est
les pâtes à la sauce algérienne sosa
ouais mais elle prend des pâtes à la
sauce algérienne dessus
cette cette année rien elle prend elle
fait n'est pas de blanche elle met de
l'asso's algérien de razac jégo banal ça
consiste en quoi la sauce algérie
machine avec un drapeau
[Applaudissements]
à jacques marchand de ragots
[Rires]
moi
non mais sans déconner la débandade
recteur 2 3 soleil qui démarre
[Applaudissements]
moi j'entraîne mentionné pas tu me
casses les couilles
tu prends ton petit orc attitude égard
la scci je vais changer de soustons mère
me bats avec l'a4 à hauteur de pareils
ça c'est bon oui alors c'est moi le
courage c'est pisser houleux le compte
de ces horribles contre je compte c'est
un gosse c'est un gros gros mollusque
avait fallu taper sur la tête non tu as
fait
tu ne goûtera
écoutant tout le temps qu'avait tu t'es
plus qu à pousser à brusque
c'est bien plus intelligent que toi
poule c est pourquoi
donc le comte s'est coupé en temps mais
ils paraissent pas que mollusques à
tokyo et une coupe en deux et après tu
le manges dégoûte c'est très très bon
j'ai découvert ça au japon ah ouais
ouais ça m'était arrivé
je partirai pas tous des banques vous
savez pourquoi faire refaire bas j'étais
parti là bas pour acheter la licence hd
haute définition
mais là-bas que j'ai vu un écran hd j'ai
dit ça marchera jamais j'ai encore une
députée
[Applaudissements]
il vous faut
monica volumes
chaînés
pôle sud j'avais acheté les poutres la
forme accepte qui sape et aaron chief un
format de cuisine en direct à la
télévision que j'ai ramené à tf1 qui
vous disent franchement base à main de
la cuisine on prend même temps quelques
idées trop tôt trop tôt
photo choisie par rabat nous raconter
j'ai en tout cas alors j'ai un truc
incroyable raconte les scènes c'est
vraiment incroyable elle a pas que vous
allez retrouver tous les échecs de match
aux éditions belle prague au
numéro un truc de numéro un comment j'ai
raté mes cinq mariages j'ai un truc de
fou il ya quelques années je voulais
j'avais une idée de télé réalité dans un
village de vacances pour m6 et donc
j'avais écrit le format est posée même
s'il m'avait dit comment tu compte
l'appeler j'avais dit les bronzés ils
m'ont dit non les bronzés c'est déposer
cqsgee non on va vérifier et c'était pas
déposer déposer les bandes et dans
toutes les classes l'éperon et cgpj m'a
fait l'émission cinq ans après j'ai eu
un coup de téléphone thierry lhermitte
qui me dit oui bonjour c'est hier les
multis qu'est ce qui attire et tout va
bien dit non ça va pas du tout je ne
peux pas sortir le film les bronzés 3
non parce que le titre était à moi non
mais oui et je les rendus gratuitement
non
j'ai déjà jetés
desaulniers hanouna
ça va nous coûter un bras
j'aurais même donné de l'argent boucler
leur inscription c'est mon frère moi
j'ai mon ami donc bien sûr je l'aurais
pas là donc gérard jugnot j'adore
après il m'a rappelé mon bien et pour
les frais de transfert de 15 cents euros
je dis pas ça par contre vous avez des
pays comme
highway quand même quand même pas notre
histoire qu'a vrai sexe et maraîchers
terre il faut j'ai fait
[Rires]
toute ma vie c'est ça non mais c'est
quoi
les licences que tu as raté aussi j'ai
d'autres casseroles de bain je sais quoi
qui a du sens à la licence hello kitty
et que vous avez failli racheter que
vous avez pas eu ça s'est su ça c'est ma
belle famille ça oui mais je voulais pas
le dire pardon
elle aussi aussi on divague ouais mais
non
quoi tes sacs poubelles mais non il ya
eu beaucoup de regrets
je suis à toi tu veux je te dis mais je
vais y arriver la réussite pas compris
les petits très bien comme ça c'est vrai
j'aurais cela c'est vrai je reste à vous
raconter nous fait toute ma vie toute ma
vie toute ma famille comme saïd fesses
de 2 22 voile noir 8 septembre ouais
mais mon père touche par contre
je pense que ma vie un oeil énorme
arrêtés et jetés ici est un petit peu
mais bien c'est vrai sa réussite des
enfants à un patron formidable et un
treuil extraordinaire extraordinaire
qu'elle se trompe de vàd accepté dans sa
loge
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et bien tout heureux et pourquoi ils
avaient toutes ces idées avant et là il
ya plus rien à perdre et là
j'en ai plein j'ai un truc géométriques
en autres il a dix mille idées à un
moment je trouve venir quand ça baisse
ça a payé sa mairie on espère ça va
arriver très ouverts comme il suffit
d'une nuit va déjà garder les yeux
fermés
ensuite dans tout le lot de ces idées
dans la tête une qui est
passé à côté d'elle pour l'instant est
pour l'instant on va là on va le garder
comme ça
si un jour et des trous qui vous parle
cd oui [ __ ] il faut vraiment que je
fasse ce truc là mais non jamais non je
vous dis souvent il faut vraiment pas
que je le fasse non je me dis bah dit
benjamin aide à vue je veux jamais
entrer notre idée pourquoi parce que je
veux tu réussis seul c'est vrai à la
force du poignet poèmes tout d'un coup
de
[Rires]
monaco arrête arrête il a signé dumas
nouvelle hausse mais non c'est vous qui
avez l'idée
lui avait fait la vache qui pleure
et
castanet bon ben on va finir à bout de
ces super sympa d'être là ça va vous oui
c'est la lamproie à la bordelaise
connaissait pas le
sexe personne qui t'a posé une question
ici oui mais mehdi ben non j'ai eu envie
de parler ah oui oui je les envie de
parler je vais continuer d'ailleurs
souhaité que les quelque chose oui ici à
direct moi j'ai passé le k rod chef moi
je passais 40 tirs
alors ne t'inquiète pas tu inquiète on
n'a pas tout mis à la porte et m'ont
lapinou tu vas parler dans un instant
c'est un gentil gars et bout comme ça en
plus et puis c'est quoi pour moi tout ce
que tu manges est propre toit fermé
armentières prototype du mec propre
bernard montiel je pourrai manger sur
lui mais je vais vous dire je le dirai
et je pense que c'est pour moi c'est
plus propre de la noria franchement il
ya kelly raymond bernard montiel
géraldine les autres
je ne suis pas je ne suis pas en
confiance mais je ne suis pas en
confiance les ricard est en jeu mais
valérie je mange pas suffisamment je
vois que c'est pas qu'elle ait pas
cacher la manche pour la bêta il ça y
est c'est terminé elle s'est cramé avec
ça